attention attention New York City oh
baby May 9th we're doing the town hall
theater in New York City for the AY live
show biggest show we've ever done
standup comedy plus we play little ay
with the crowd grab the squad come out
and see us yeah gang all tickets are
available at rug garbage.com get them
now they're going to go fast we love to
see it air welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedian are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is Ru garbage oh it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
they grew it to be classy yeah or if
they're just a big old piece of trash
trash trash trash I'm your host H Foley
coming at you on a festive day we're out
back here at toies in the new edition
Christmas season is full swing uhhuh my
co-host is coming at you and you're
dressed for Halloween what the heck are
we doing
here you know what I looked into your
eyes and you weren't getting a toty to
squeak I didn't like
it my co-host is coming at from across
the table it's what we call a family
episode here in the community just the
boys the bozos and the homies just the
where we like it give it up for Kippy
Kevin James Outlaw Ryan hey what's up
everybody thanks for tuning gang please
make sure you rate you subscribe on
iTunes full video available on YouTube
as you know those numbers are T cooking
cooking then obviously the greatest
website of all time I didn't like that
www.patreon.com you garbage gang go over
there you get all your stuff you need
a we're on a Fritz over here somebody
pull me out and blowing me huh like you
got the full some Prison Blues on your
mind over there Cowboy how about a nice
quick shout out to I turn you into a PT
why you're dressed like a pumpkin it's
just Polo believe Tim Dylan has the same
one as well the Tim Dylan you my friend
or no Tim D I'm not man he's been
killing me lately yeah he's good that's
he's good how about a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
old magic man works the ones the twos
the threes and the fours he crosses the
te's and he dots the eyes Kippy may be
dressed apart but he's the fastest gun
in the East give it up for T-Bone
McStuffins Toby McMullen everybody what
up dude
really trying to work that denim huh big
man yeah test it well in the focus
groups who
Patty what's he
wearing all right give me bounce me
three bits go I tell you that Patty
Foley really living her best life out
there sure woo tripping the Lights
Fantastic traveling staying extra days
Jersey ain't travel she down in Texas
down in Delaware she was down in Texas
oh yeah doing spots at the Mothership
kid's making moves I tell you do you
know Joe
Rogan do you know my fat son what you
want to see I'm
sorry uh I got a little something I want
to get into lay it on um a little more
hard feelings ask but you know we can
roll our sleeves up and get into it I
was out to dinner with my family the
whole lot of them 13 of us you got me
you got my wife you got my my mom my
sister brother mother-in-law their kids
brother sister-in-law their kids that is
a lot of chicken tenders and butter
noodles oh you ain't lying um shout out
to it by the way um what's that the
chicken tender oh man I'm always too
treat no the Nuggets or anything the
fries whatever the kids get I'm dabbling
it you picking up this check Kip no all
right 13 people what are you nuts I'm
upside down in a house in the BBS
picking up the check um let me get me
and the four little
ones I could have I could have uh uh
who's drinking all these Shirley temples
do [__] five five Shirley temples in
a lemonade every time did they get them
yeah really Shirley temps and a little
one don't like them she gets a lemonade
how many are they allowed to have just
one it depends how many it depends if
they're
driving I got big wheels outside you got
a meeting tomorrow um in those in those
instances the parents are relaxed we're
all at the one end we're having it's
kind of you know and there's they're
they're old enough to just order on
their own three three I don't know wow
it's also I think at that point it's
like we got one I think it's like the
wheels are off my all the adults are
drinking so it's like hey you finally
[__] you guys talk to each other
we're down here we got one and that
first one as I don't got to tell you
guys that went down quick I was never a
[__] St man myself whatever you got
the soda cakes and I had no Governor you
didn't like a Roy Rogers with a little
cherry juice in there I don't know what
that is it's a Shirley Temple but with h
Cola no I was coke screaming huh yeah
two strolls so I can get it down quicker
[__] so I can Mainline this thing D that
grenadine is no joke have you ever heard
of a Dirty Shirley I went to school at
one is it just vodka in there probably
yes sir yeah um so right okay we're
having a few cocktails me and the adults
right I'm at the end of the table head
of the table no no no one's at the head
I'm at the end okay right I'm on the
flank as you would call right I'm the
last guy in uh I'm quarterbacking a
little bit cuz that's where the waiters
coming to you know what I mean for kind
of everybody I've assumed head of the
table
status yeah i' I've me and my brother
will flipflop on it oh yeah yeah you you
take it I have it you take it you know
still not picking up the check though
what you got to pick up the check if
you're at the end of the table not in my
house no I asked for a high chair just
to keep things even keep it keep it on
an even Keel baby got a booster
seet um going on they put a chair on the
in for me it's like hey you won't fit in
the booth man that's
true I'm in booths though that's go you
are you are I haven't I haven't run
across a booth that I couldn't get in in
a in in a while mhm they're not
comfortable yeah you're in you're part
of the booth at one it's a waffle house
that would like to speak
differently I push it out if it's locked
in like what do we [__] what is this
a [__] Panic Room let get some little
give on this for you Jesus Christ got a
[__] salt shaker in your belly button
um so
waiter newer it seems newer a little
flustered definitely not the man for a
13 person table and I get or you know uh
coming together all at once yeah bang
bang s but we're also like and he was
kind of doing he's like hey we can get
the kids stuff in now get them situation
you guys can chill drop it was good I
think he was just you know it wasn't a
in his defense you got to you got you
got that's that's that's a two-man job
especially getting the ordering and
getting everybody situated sure uh and a
manager did kind of come over and help
Flex he had run it was he did a good job
but it was a little he was a little just
forgetting stuff and you know he's like
dude at one point which we don't care
like we're not a [__] we don't make
no noise how do you forget when 12 of
the 13 people order the same thing there
was a lot of burgers going around it's
just chicken BM as far as the I can see
so I mean we're all you know Blue Collar
Working Class People everybody's
weighted tables in my family everybody
you know something so no one and it's
also like hey as long we're just
chilling drinking like you know we we're
like we don't have a show to get to
we're like it's not we're catching
dinner in a show and we're like hey show
starts at 8 like we're chilling for
three whatever like there's no rush
we're chilling so the guy is just a
little wonky and like you know he'd
leave we all be like what the hell is
that all you know it's just you know
he's just making it weird the whole time
so uh he kept forgetting drinks and I
get that cuz he would come and he with
my
family better [__] hey I don't keep
the chicken marcala give me the [__]
give me the [__] Bud Light put the
the silverware on the back burner just
keep the [__] Manhattan coming so
we're drinking beers and uh I'm I'm
pretty heavy into the this is this is we
he keeps forgetting them so he'd be like
he' like anything else like oh that one
IPA or that oh and he go oh right yeah
and it's just you know no one's holding
it against them it's he's he's in the
weed you running dry at certain points
well once I realize the slowness of it I
get ahead of it you're doing two not two
but like if I'm halfway done and someone
else is getting one I'll be like throw a
light on it
sure so it gets down to the end and I
order we're like wrapped up at this
point and I go can I get uh just one
more Bud Light and he goes and my
brother goes yeah I'll do a he was doing
an IPA or something or Corona or
something so he's like
yeah
so uh five minutes goes by we're talking
you know whatever he comes back uh check
dropped with the check and
goes uh if there's nothing else uh you
know here's the check and I go I'm just
still waiting on that Bud Light
uhhuh and he goes I brought it and I'm
like I yeah I don't think you did and he
goes I can assure you sir o I brought
your Bud Light and now I'm like you just
threw down I'm like well where is it I'm
like I don't I 9-year-old the end of the
table got a cherry in it to play it off
like a Shirley Temple
I'm like I didn't you know I'm like I
didn't get it I didn't I don't have it
at that point you just say well can I
have another one I so then he goes I can
I was taken AB I think as that I can
assure you you were drunk I was Dr I was
pretty [__]
up and also I might have had it I don't
know are you serious no no I don't think
I don't think so but this cans or Dr
bottle or Dr cans what kind of place you
going to is giving you cans at the table
what the hell kind of gin joints you you
eat got them aluminum bottles oh man
those what am I a Socks game what's
going on here wait are they are they
giraffes giraffes you drinking budlike
giraffes they were going down God damn
what brutal no is czy got to have that
in a bottle I'm a can man myself but at
dinner I CL it up a little bit um there
I to me there's only certain things you
can drink in a bottle at a day it's got
to be a elevated beer or a Corona so you
can't be drinking I think a straight
Budweiser always looks good on any table
I agree wait why Corona it's a a little
festive you know what I mean it's a
little different Corona never draft
bottle for sure yeah Corona is made out
of a bottle that's why it's like without
question I'm saying why is why does
Corona cross the acceptable cuz that's a
that's a bottled beer you don't pour
that into a glass I'd be with you on
that I don't know if that would look all
right I think I think an American the
lime classes things up let's not get
that's what I'm saying so Corona is fine
in a bottle is what I'm saying all right
what if you had a nice Italian joint you
can't have a Corona you could have a
nice they got it on a menu I'm not my
own all right right no okay so he goes I
an Italian place with a coron on the
tables whack yeah well then why are they
I don't think they're serving Corona you
got a Peroni oh okay I'll give you that
yeah I would say an Italian restaurant
isn't serving konas fell enough probably
a Peroni yeah probably a Peroni gentle
which looks all right on the table what
about hinin ah hin okay you don't like
hinin but yeah hinin I think I think hin
go a glass at the bottle and the glass
is there especially this time year sure
oh a pilsner glass with with a a frosted
pillner glass with a hinin around the
holidays
woo I'll give you the Christmas spirit
they always give me heart I have them
linked to heartburn and indigestion and
throwing up cuz every that's every beer
for me every time you go they only
that's the only beer they served at the
after hours clubs in Philly so you go
from two you drinking whatever and then
you get there and I was I shouldn't have
been there you know I'm like bubbling up
already and I try to try to hammer down
it's like it's like going down like
rocks yeah so he goes I can assure you
sir I brought it damn what the [__]
what's with the attitude I know why not
just go it's a monster check oh big
check and he goes he goes I hey my mom's
not paying she an
enslave to buy to get her [__] adult
son's drunk for me to get this attitude
um but it was also one of those things
where like everybody kind of turned away
cuz it was like oh this it was weird
enough that he put it they all there
there there are only two words in the
service industry that would give you the
confidence for to say something like
that that's automatic gratuiti baby yeah
true party of 13 that's a auto 18%
brother you ain't lying that's true I'm
draggon ass and I'm getting paid already
done and that means he didn't get the
vibe the family was going to add a
little extra yeah we were with our MD
lights and chicken
fingers I don't know what to tell you
kid 13 people ate for 85 bucks you drew
the short stroll man that additional
gratuiti Line's getting redacted what a
black stamp to whom it may
concern um so I uh so I'm like that's
weird and everybody's like oh it got
like tents and the manager's and he goes
uh if you want me to add one I can and I
was like nah no need but you didn't now
I'm I'm like you didn't bring it you
know what I mean like I think you know
your beer intake enough I would assume
so in my head this whole conversation is
happening while you're holding two
beers you're a liar
sir also got two in his feet like like a
gorilla also we got to a bar after that
and I sculled the first one I'm like
maybe I did drink that beer Jesus like I
looked at how quick I deleted that one I
was like either way either way you just
go oh do you want I can grab another one
for whatever like yeah as a server he
threw me like now we're in a debate and
I'm it's not fair cuz I'm
drunk and sir please put your shirt back
on so I'm like all right and then all
what I don't like right so I'm like N I
do the same I do the polite thing n it's
okay he's like you sure I can add one to
the I can go back and add one to the go
buddy no sweat all good I thought you
know whatever maybe I drank it I don't
know like I I dove on the grenade and
was polite and you know just moved
forward he then goes so then the
manager's next to him and hears this and
the manager's at the other table like
open in a bottle of wine or something
and the manager goes for refined
people the manager goes Check Your Right
pocket
[__] he goes I'll buy you a beer if
you need one and I went you'll W go what
now now I'm offended financially I'm
offended as an alcoholic I'm offended as
let me run up by your mom I can buy you
a beer if you need one I go who I can
buy you you a beer I go I can now I can
buy now I'm like now I'm doing that
thing I'm pulling out credit C I can buy
a beer you know what I mean like
Mom let me hold 20 you pull a purse up
on the table tell me reaching into it
dirt ball I can afford a beer if you
spread it over these two
cards see this this is a Discover card
sir hey when do you guys submit these to
American
Express I got to move a couple things
around yeah and he I go no no it's okay
and he goes now it's a now all the other
tables are like it's a and I'm like no
man it's okay and he goes he said two
time I'll buy you a beer if you want me
to buy you a beer I'll buy you a beer I
go even if you are the manager and
you're trying to smooth just say ah let
me grab you a beer don't say you'll buy
me one cuz now you've you've introduced
money into it like I can't afford a beer
and don't tell me I can't afford some
cuz I I'll buy 10 of them yeah I was
[__] flabbergasted huh it should be
on the house I'll get you one on the
house I'll grab you a beer no not even
that I'll grab you a beer I got you oh
yeah or just go get it and just put it
there go it's a [__] budlike draft
what are we talking about two nickel
yeah give me a break I know them I know
them lines are dirty too I was thily
embarrassed whoa yeah I can assure you I
brought your beer also if you need if
you need me to buy you one I will were
you wearing that jean
jacket wasn't my finest black T-shirt um
did this come across uh mom's radar yeah
everybody dude the whole back we were in
like a back guarden of this like you
know the outdoor seating and do you know
anything about the finances was it was
the gratuiti at it already yeah 13 yeah
that's added okay uhhuh all right but
that's as far as you know as far as I
know yeah and I think I did she take any
offense to it or I mean everybody was
just like that was crazy [__] awkward
like that none of like that could have
been a every one of that's not going to
affect her though she's still she's
going to do the right thing always oh
yeah yeah I think we even Juiced him
again on top of it God damn it yeah I
mean he did well he just CED a [__] T
at the end sure yeah I I don't you know
it I understand it's but just [__]
give me to beer and let's move on why
call the scene you know what that means
you look like a bozo oh yeah dude man
not good no no this guy don't even think
I can buy a beer do you remember when
the check was dropped where it was put
in front of me really yeah and I went sh
see that's interesting yeah he thinks
I'm paying for it yet he's still going
to [__] stiff me on a be on a beer I
mean I'm guessing 13 people that's
probably it's well over 500 creeping
towards a g I think it was like
78 yeah and he can't and he puts it puts
it in front of you uhhuh so he had the
respect thinking you were paying which
he was
wrong this guy's been wrong all
night
how can I trust him he thinks I got to
eat hunch for dinner holy [__] and then
not buying these not no just as a
because you know I'm a dirt ball and you
don't slap the hand that feeds you so if
if I'm if I'm even if the guy's a dick
not saying that you
were but you're you're
insinuated I can assure
you I am not if I was a [__] would
but if I'm putting the check even with
the
18 with the with the gratuiti at it I'm
still expecting a little juice so I'm
not going to [__] that up just yet
unless I've ruined the meal which I've
done plenty of times when I when I was
working sure just [__] it up just
forgot everything but if I'm handing it
to you now if the check was already
dropped in front in front of your in
front of Mommy and and why do we have to
call her that and you pipe up then it's
like well I got you but it was ordered
prior to
this yeah but still running his mouth it
felt like he dropped the check and I'm
like oh give me a
beer dropping the check in front of you
and then giving you attitude is Crazy M
yeah that's I don't know how you deal
with a guy like that guy got nothing to
lose I
know this guy's playing by his own
[__] rules man man yikes but it is
what it is and you know just thoroughly
embarrassed at the whatever did he
tussle your hair or anything when he
dropped the check pull my [__] rubbed
on my ear you don't need another one of
those
I don't want you pissing the bed later
how to Shirley Temple huh buddy yeah it
was that that is what it is you know
this is pretty litter shout out to
pretty litter all you cat mommies and
daddies out there and I know there's a
lot of them you want to take care of the
little angel as best as you possibly can
and I'm going to tell you how to do that
it's a pretty litter you guys know that
you're huge cat lovers that's why we're
obsessed with today's sponsor pretty
litter that was copy tried to make it
off the cuff didn't work pretty litter
still a great product put the little
tinies in there tells you're wrong with
the kitty cat or not plus it lasts
longer and makes the house smell great I
don't think I saw tinies in the uh in
the copy in addition to making sure uh
you're informed about your cat's Health
this literal also traps odors as well
tells you have potential illness in the
cat such as UTI kidney issues and much
more great uh you can have family and
friends over for the holidays without
worrying about the secretly think your
house smells horrible uh yeah get you
ever smell that somebody you walk in
somebody's cat litter stinks he puts not
with pretty you wouldn't even know until
you see the little baby come around the
cornery pretty litter God stop doing
that pretty litter is lightweight low
dust and one six lb bag works up to an
entire month without clumping baby they
take care of you it don't Clump I'll
tell you that it's great uh you can
count on pretty litter to keep your
house smelling fresh and clean uh go to
prettylitter.com
garbage to save 20% off your first order
that's prettylitter.com garbage to save
20% off your first order one more time
prettylitter.com garbage terms and
conditions apply C sa for details k
let's talk about sheath underwear put my
D and my bees in two separate pouches
called a day you when you you been
sticking your little 2 iner andm for a
long time now inch and a half but sure
it's cold out there gang she thunderwear
is the best in the biz they've been a
sponsor since Jump Street we love them
developed by a veteran shout out to over
there in Iraq cuz it was getting sticky
down there his nuts were sticking to his
leg army Sergeant Roger Patton Robert
Patton now he's got the pouch you throw
it in there underwear look great they
feel great do yourself a favor pick up a
pair it's a game changer uh I never
really ever thought about it whatever
underwear and I'm a bigger guy I know we
got a lot of bigger guys walking around
you got to care that that that
antimicrobial the smell it takes care
you can wear them two three days in a
row without nothing without batting an
eye at them be are a little secret um my
uh schlong looks and feels amazing I
would say look it looks better uh yours
well too stock up on sheath underwear
and give those crown jewels some air
flow go to sheath underwear. comom and
use the code garbage you get 20% off
your first order plus sheath underwear's
100% money back guarantee that sheath
under that sheath underwear. comom promo
code garbage get sheath underwear
support the show support your balls love
you sheath yeah real quick on that uh on
on the booze thing and I don't want to
let anybody down I don't know if it's
just that I'm getting older if it's the
OES or what it is I'm switching to
heroin less calor switched um I can't do
ipas anymore I yeah I'm I've been off
them for a year I can't unless it's got
to be 33 de it's got to be
screaming screaming cold I don't like
the way they make me feel the next day
I'm like M first of all they [__] me up
like with Bud Lights or what bud Heavies
or pbrs like I I can ride that Dragon I
can manage them the whole time IPA is
that the exponential growth around like
seven or eight where like each one is
another three you know what I mean like
it's compounded annually or [__]
daily on you yeah I like I like a golden
ale I was drinking Kaa golden ale o nice
hang 10 bro yeah dude all right yeah
tubular but all that aside we got a
goddamn Family episode gang uh you guys
know when you join a patreon uh can uh
we answer your garbage question on air
it's just the best way to do it patreon
gets the first crack add it shout out to
the
homies uh all right this one's just
funny this was from Garfield lasagna
everywhere hat while pulling your PUD
wear a hat like if you that's you're too
not ready for that I feel have you ever
had a hat
on Jo your and masturbated huh that
seems
to you're either if I'm all charged up
and I like go into my room and lay down
and go to work but you don't take your
hat off you got to have your hat that's
weird that's comes off in the middle of
it that's like having your shoes on what
you've never done that with my shoes on
yeah I don't think so he not it's like
shaving you go in you just get it done
no he's a nice lady he lights a candle
he sets the mood huh you got to give me
nine Bud Light shoes for sure I don't
think and hat I would say maybe I feel
like I've like I can somehow visualize
me in the middle and like I Cowboy out
on good day
sir I got a war helmet on can I can I
trouble you for the wifi code
[Laughter]
I'll be back in a minute partner you
watch my horse
um yeah no that's crazy it's a that's a
it's a casual experience for me
hm yeah no no shoes no shoes no shirt no
service uh really yeah no shoes no hat
huh not that I know of you never just
had to get it out of you and just gone
in and done your business but where
where I I don't have shoes on at my
house yeah had on I'm just picturing
like a guy with a trucker hat and a
truck with a bench sheet in front of a
lake for some reason yeah sunglasses on
for sure really oh that guy or you no me
oh y guys playing face and L I don't
know that's it seems real like you're
trying to hide who it seems like
criminal to me what with the hat yeah
it's a disguise pull down
low got a fake beard on yeah I don't get
I don't like it it's a little too not
relaxed huh all right definitely garbage
I mean yes for sure weird I mean the
first thing I do when I get home is I
take my hat off if I'm wearing a hat I'm
not sitting on the couch wearing a hat I
wear it in I forget that it's on wear it
in sometimes yeah I mean sometimes but
like as a rule of thumb I could shoes
and hat are coming off when I get into a
domicile I'll wear my Phillies hat
sometimes when I watch if I watch
Phillies games at my house if you're
masturbating dooring a Phillies game no
you got have you seen Bryce Harper yeah
good point God if you are wearing a hat
I feel like you got to flip it to the
back yeah yeah dud like you're Stone and
over the
top have you ever had intercourse with a
hat on that's when you flip it to the
back I don't think so yeah
beanie a beanie outdoors in the
winter Jesus where are you Alaska what
what the [__] who's doing that outdoor
the winner outdoor in the winner God
love you it's too cold for me no
I only do indoor games after a certain
time of the year I like a
dome you're
nuts are you kidding me Outdoors you
like dealing with the wind that's like
that's like wearing white after Labor
Day
uh-uh n The Patio gets closed early at
the [__] that folley you're nuts yeah
Jesus Christ I enough trouble if it's
[__] perfect conditions I need the
habitable
zone uh on that same tip this is from
Kyle ever wear a beanie over a baseball
hat that was a look for a while crazy I
well I did for sure Junior High skating
days was remember when the beanie with
the brim came out that was a [__]
game changer oh the Tom Penny the Tom
peny why was it that Tom Penny he's a
pro skater who rocked the beanie with
visor yeah they were oh the radar hat
yeah yeah I I wanted to
make that work for me it would took a
very certain guy you had to be slender I
feel something I was like too it just
didn't work as radar O'Reilly is who I
was referring to from Mash you wore one
of those or big uh lots of dreads if you
had bunch of dreads in there uhhuh yeah
maybe pull it off but I liked it on
paper that looked cool cuz you could
like casually go to the back to side
with it I mean they were der you were
not a classy guy rocking one of those
you was a kid where it was like you
definitely have single parent type thing
he had a cigarette tucked in there yeah
I would do that too in a beanie s in a
beanie working man for sure there was a
long time when I was working uh with my
family construction comp there was a
long time I was Sig in the ear was like
on on Deck Sig in the ear is all right I
still do it like around here like
whatever Sig in the Sig in the beanie or
a Sig in the visor turned backwards
who's doing that what not one guy ever
pulled that off
no one's ever crazy guy killer uh I also
I want to say too that there was a thing
with the Packa in the beanie flap for a
while do you remember that I could I
could have just been my my buddy's
brother did that no I can see that in
like a world like a Vietnam guy with his
Sig up there sure it was kind of similar
to
that like a dude at a gas
station where you from back in the world
McMullen you're going to make fun of me
for this nuh
but uh for about four months I was doing
the pack of heaters rolled up on my
sleeve I mean yeah you of that doesn't
Shock Me pulp fixing had just come out
and I was in high school uhhuh yeah soft
pack I I get I you know I relatively get
it I it makes sense it's a cool look hot
cool dudes pull it off nah not me I'm
the dudes that do pull it off are hot
you were not a hot cool dude yeah you
were good looking I'm sure at that time
who's the kid elbowed the good-looking
kid Butler I don't know Austin Butler he
could pull that off sure I think it also
takes a specific t-shirt to look cool
intoo which you do not have no I tried
that one time I was in my room I rolled
it up I looked I went who do I think I
am took it out just you're FL got be
able to fight if you do that yeah or
have a hot rod yeah have a switchblade
on and like a chick with big bumblebee
hair uh-huh the big the sheriff chasing
you around because he knew you were no
good you're from the wrong side of the
tracks what you're doing all right you
turn it around uh yeah that was I mean
beanies in I mean that they got like
cool when we skate like seventh for me
it was like sixth seventh eighth grade
into high school like having a cool
skate beanie or something and then those
visors dropped that was a [__] they
were not cool when I was a kid they were
not they were you didn't want I remember
as like a younger kid it was they were
like nerdy we called them stocking hats
put your stocking hat on it's freezing
outside it was the last thing you wanted
brutal mhm [__] your hair up cuz they
changed and I did the well they went
from the old school like flip up which
were dorky to the beanie the actual
beanie without the flip up the
fisherman's is what where it starts was
was the fisherman was or like what
Mickey wore in Rocky it didn't go below
the ears that's when they that's that
was that that's the better
beanie without question they got to be
shorter and like smaller and Tighter we
wore monsters oh man they were so they
look iy was wearing like a gourd on my
head they were a specific kind of fabric
to they weren't the cool kind of fabric
had a ball or something on the top and
itchy if you got a little bit of snow in
there and it melted rubbing with your
oven mitts on man Jam you up that's a
tough look yes very um were you guys
plastic bags over the shoes winter guys
yeah rubber bands yeah never worked I
feel like you know they would always get
wet but yeah that was huge for a very
long time just the most embar
embarassing feeling yeah what were you
wearing that what were you ice fishing
you didn't do that when you were playing
in the snow no I [__] snow boots Put
your snow boots on and bibs we had bibs
what are bibs overalls yeah like no no
we had overalls on too like snow pants
with the clip snow pants they were cool
yeah I remember no they weren't cool
these were brutal no I they they became
those became cool again but the coolest
thing I though I got him may I want to
say like eighth grade on sale at like
some snowboard skate show shop was
called the G-spot actually my Mom hated
taking me to that place and I didn't
know why still
don't that place is a
myth it's a great store you can never
find it no no yeah [__] um keep going
a little further a little
further what about this huh
that I never knew I mean we started
going in like sixth grade maybe it was a
big not big it was a standalone house
that they these [__] reefer heads
turned into a skate shop which shout out
to it it was called the G-spot it was on
Route One in Fairless Hills right by the
oxer Valley Mall purple store and it
just said the G-Spot and I had no clue
and I remember my mom being like I don't
like taking it into this place and I'm
like ah whatever you know but I got a
pair of uh snow pants that looked like
not looked but like were jean cut you
know what I mean and they were thin they
were thin they like they dude they were
like light gray [__] you put a belt on
them and Stu and I was like like man
this is the epitome of Co those are cool
do you remember you guys remember Gators
like the gers no Gators I think that's
how they were called Gators it was when
you skied in jeans they were like uh
they were like windbreaker material
they'd go from your ankle to your knees
to keep you uh like
dry um pretty sure it was Gators I think
I know what you're talking about they
were like just for the ankle like up to
like the the the yeah remember dude
dudes would rock them older kids would
rock them like [__] that's cool mhm I
mean couldn't pull it off nothing's
cooler than mittens that convert into
the fingerless gloves oh man I remember
one those dropped too mittens dude get
out of here that convert into the
fingerless you got the Flop the turkey
neck hanging down get out of here smoke
and pick pockets they got cool that was
snowboarders again snowboarders did that
cuz it was mittens so you could Buckle
like mittens got cool for snowboarders
around some time cuz it was like anti it
was like you know ironic that they were
cool and then they once they had those
that flipped out catch he you could do
your [__] do your bindings and stuff
it was all right hatte it man I was a
freaky freezers man what you remember
freaky on another planet you remember
freaky freezers they were gloves that
had like a little like design on them
and it only came out when that sounds
like an ice cream that ended in a class
action
lawsuit oh oh [__] freaky freezers I had
these uhuh I had this exact one the
robot yeah whoa only they only you only
could see the the thing when it got cold
man they tasted a certain
way hold on I know what you're talking
about when they got a little wet the
foam underneath yeah cuz you have to
like bite to like pull them I would bite
to pull them off man woo out plus you
get a little little rock salt on there
delicious salt to taste
huh um eating your gloves damn that's a
that was a [__] Blast from the Past
were huge we had a trash bag I had to
get a pair of secondhand from my cousin
my mom mom would never buy them they
were probably my brothers or even
somebody got we had a a black trash bag
that smelled I could smell it to this
day filled with the winter stuff in the
front closet so it was the hats the neck
warmer a scarf a whatever and it would
be in there man and that first you'd be
digging looking for the other one of
those freaky freezers you can never
there's a hole in the one yeah it was
good times I didn't know they were
branded like that the robot freaky
freezer that's what I had they were huge
back in the day in the 80s they were
[__] huge there's if you didn't have
them you were I got to get a pair of
them dude um damn all right this one's
from uh my boy Pat friend of the show
there you go he texted me this which I
never thought do you say mirror or
mirror as in check the rear viiew mirror
check the rearview mirror mirror mirror
yeah mirror rearview mirrror rearview
mirror but look in the mirror which is
weird is there a
mirror I think I just say mirror for
regular for for for the mirr the thing
you look at to look at yourself in is a
mirror the thing to check behind is a
rearview mirror mirror yeah no second R
in there mirror no just mirror rearview
mirror rearview mirror it's weird sounds
real hillbilly
mhm Mirror Mirror rearview mirror
rearview mirror miror mirror I don't
know I think mine's like me e r e r yeah
mirror yeah like a mirr cat mirr cat
Manor shout out to that show
um all right and the same thing this is
from uh eight effing aprons $10 homie um
how do you pronounce
wheelbarrow wheelbarrow or Barrel it's
barrel for me I think we've touched on
this I'm sure we have at some point all
of my life and even now as we sit here
it's wheel barrel it's a barrel it's a
barrel on Wheels yes well what's a
barrel is nothing Barrel outside of
wheel wheelbarrow barel is a thing
Barrow is probably like an old world
container or something yeah container I
had no idea F me my Barrow I had no idea
it was a
wheelbarrow what do you got on that
T-Bone a two- wheeled hand cart used
especially by Street vendors British
that's the Barrow and it also known as a
took me Barrow also known as a luggage
trolley a luggage trolley dude that's
great man those Brits are goofy bananas
they really are so oh God go to a den
get a real dictionary someone commented
on this D episode like 30 seconds in
when he said he was born in London we
both like hell it like immed I'm like
it's such a knee-jerk reaction to scream
the second you hear it a wheelbarrow
wheel yeah that's um I say wheelbarrow
wheelbarrow yeah yeah wheelbarrow i'
I've also I've it's because of the show
and obviously now like talking for a
living and so much that I've come I've
just accepted and you have two of just
like the words I say are wrong I'm fine
with does that make sense I'm very okay
with that I'm like yeah that's just
wheelbarrow everybody knows what I'm
saying li like Library it's Library it's
I'm never going to say library is that
even they should take your MX away yeah
I don't say that they can because it's
say it again
liary yeah li like a new flavor of white
cloth the library people who pronounce
library library have never been in one
yeah even I say that Library
yeah no I'm not I you're not going to
shame me I just said I'm finally owning
this and I'm owning it man I didn't know
that uh-huh I say others like uh Jesus
you're running this
operation that's a little
unnerving plus you don't have many Bud
Lights you had maybe I just realized
maybe that's that guy's way of flagging
Me Maybe he thought I was too drunk I
was like yeah I'll bring it to them
maybe maybe they had a they had a board
meeting like you had it you old sauce
sauce whatever ever it is yeah damn but
I'm owning it I say a bunch of stuff
weird and I'm fine with it I'm just fill
up a bottle of beer with water heyy you
go pop up drink that all right this
one's from Matthew uh is it garbage to
drink of fountain soda when the ice is
already melted
e changes it's not great fresh ice yeah
but I mean fresh ice it is it kind of
gets like it kind of scratches the itch
but it just doesn't it's just cut with
that much more
if it's like been sitting in the cup
holder in the car oh and you take it's
usually kind of warm that first wave of
ice really takes a punishment too
they're the first guys on the beach oh
by the time the second wave when you go
to you got you got to do fresh ice oh
yeah of course got to that's crazy it
also depends on the ice sometimes you
get that soft ice that kind of goes
quick if you get some hard nice good ice
ruins it it ruins it I know dude like I
I just picture a McDonald's cup and like
it kind of separates the the water and
the
coke it has that light film uhhuh it's
like pond water I know but I'll [__]
I'll still drink it I don't give I don't
give two shits always fresh ice um I'm I
I've lately been ordering a second cup
of ice whoa yeah and give me a give me
the example hey you're at at a bar or
dinner uh anywhere Hey sir what can I
get you um can I do a my tie with a cup
of ice on the side whoa yeah and what
just using my ties as a thing sure and
then you're just pouring that in there
yeah and then pouring pouring taking the
cup and pouring it into the container
with ice and then drinking out of that
and then filling it up as as need be
that's PR I like a lot of ice that's
pretty hoyy toyy like a lot of ice huh
especially when I'm doing my business
when I'm crossing the river sure I got
to get [__] up MH I I've said before
about one of my brothers all time dirt
bag moves was to order a double crown on
the Rocks no double crown yeah double
crown on the
Rocks take a couple SW like sip it for
you know five minutes or whatever so
you're like getting a couple shots of
you know couple and then go hey can you
he'd go to the BART tier can you Splash
a little Coke in this so then so for the
price of one you get a you get a couple
straight rips off the crown then you get
a crown of coke gentle dude I remember
being like he's like yeah they don't
charge he's like you get a free you get
a couple [__] wax off it and then
you're walking around with a free mixed
drink yeah we we figured out I like that
that's all right no bartender is going
to give you [__] get a little splash of
diet in there there you go especially if
you're [__] whacking them off unless
you get that [__] and you just paid
for a you just paid for a double crown
so you're cool yeah because a because a
crown in a rocks is more expensive than
a crown in Coke right yeah yeah yeah
significantly but I'm saying like you
he'd probably take like four swigs and
also I think it was a way not to get too
you know and then he would do like
another one of those maybe that's what
I'll start I remember a guy C on was
like what you can't you're just like
double dipping drinks
here we figured out a bar in Chicago
charge the same thing for a shot of
Jameson as Jameson neat which is a
healthier poor talk about Black Friday
BR that was a deal for the ages M well
famously we I mean when we were real
when we were doing shows at Niagara bar
alltime great New York City Bar
uh dive seventh and a seventh and a lot
of shows in that back room it's kind of
like where punk rock started in New York
too it was it was a famous uh venue
called 7A or 7 and a or something they
have like a historical New York City
plaque in there of like all these like
the [__] Ramones and [__] have played
there but they would give you they had a
they had a buy one get one system
remember that yeah from 5 to 7 if I
think we we I think we stopped it yeah
cuz it was from 5: to 7:00 so if you
would buy a
beer they would would give you a free
token for a beer right so we would buy a
bunch of beers during and they were
cheaper they were cheaper they were like
$3 instead of $5 so we'd buy a bunch and
get the tokens and then wait for them to
wait till after happy hour that was on
our love affair with Goose Island
started up man the blackouts in that
place man good night Goose Island ipas
screaming C doing pints
too yeah no chalice is over there and
then they finally called on they're like
you can't
we so we'd save the we we'd have like a
stack of chips till they were $5 beers
and walk up to the bar all in dud roll
roll in there after eight bang bang Bang
Yeah we take them home come back with
them the next night dud they were like
at one point they like how many of these
do you guys have like [__] zip it
will you cuz we' get some for running
the show too I might have gotten to the
bag at one point too there was a bag of
them oh a little too close to
them it was it was killer be killed in
them streets dude
those were tough times but it is what it
is great bar though great bar to go in
and get hammered also you know the walls
of that on a cold night yeah the famous
artist the famous I think it's a famous
Japanese artist he was just in there one
night drunk and like it was empty and he
just they let him draw all over the
walls and now they were like these walls
are worth like $5 million or something
like that they're behind plexiglass now
it's just like this famous Japanese
artist Doodles it's pretty crazy you
can't get me on a Goose Island I got the
chip jaming me up I'm back there
bombing I don't think I ever did well in
that place that place was a bomb box I
ate [__] back there oh man every time
how yeah you were there one night right
hanging out yeah good times damn really
thought we were doing it getting drunk
in New York City in the winter oh there
ain't nothing better stumbling out don't
need a you should have a jacket but
you're so drunk when you're catching a
heater you're all right freshen you up a
little bit it's like a cup of coffee I
got to step outside get my bearings I
got to drive out of here check my tokens
make sure I'm flush with the next couple
of rounds otherwise I got to dip out uh
all right this one's from Jacob hey
bozos $10 homie here uh never had one
read what kind of license plate frame
are you
rocking I do you have one no but I had
the option to have one but I didn't use
it it's the place where we got
dealership yeah yeah no I'm I'm rocking
a carvana one that I have to take off
[__] just I got mean that on your new
car you lose I know I just hav yeah holy
[__] nerd alert dude such a nerd every
time I see it I'm like man you're a dork
I even debated um they they put like
this they're trashy they put the sticker
on the back of the car now like from the
the decal from where you got it from
bergy's Auto Group yeah I I was going to
try to wipe that off I didn't know how
they'd feel about that uhuh but then I
realized if if when I'm done this lease
I can take oh boy here we go I can take
that to like side have a Jeep I could go
to a Ford dealership and trade it in
over
there uh so they would change the decal
anyway sure right
sure I don't know I just got an offer to
get to to they want me in a new key of
forte 2023 whoa yeah I said you're the
reason I got jammed up in the first
place you're a [__] car you got yeah
this one they can steal easier so so
they don't break your windows yeah we we
actually give them the
keys yeah that's a tough look man oh did
you hear what I I heard uh unless it's
like you know US Navy or something like
that or like the college I something
real classy like chain link that's if on
a low rider you got to have chain link
that's all right that guy can fight yeah
chain link something subtle unless it
goes with the car like if you have like
some sort of low rider or something you
know you can do something of that ilk
but that's the only time you can do that
yeah the chain link barrier is absolute
drag I might get a chain link barrier
now that we talk about it class it up a
little bit let them know I'm from the
street yeah it may look
pretty it used to be
corvana H yeah it's a tough look dude um
yeah that's they're not classy ever if
you throw yosity Sam or any type of uh
Looney Tunes character anything Looney
Tunes on anything is is a tough look for
a minute it wasn't though I like a Road
Runner mud flap on a on a 18wheeler mud
flaps are fun yeah yeah mud flaps are
all right they're all right you know
yeah yosity with the double barrel or
whatever that's all right um feel like
mud flaps have gone out of style they
still have those on big rigs yeah they
do mhm okay
huh
get a pair for
you you ever get jammed up on your bike
what do you mean when you were a kid
with mud flaps the well they they have
them I see the delivery guys they have
like a oh so the rain doesn't fly up
yeah I didn't know that when I was a
little fat kid in [__] eighth grade
zipping around on my bike showing up to
my buddy's house I [__] my pants yeah
you know what I mean dude you got the
line up from the ass crack all the way
up to your neck look going to a little
hangout by the playground with some
chicks holy [__] is pants just hanging
out on the outside of the circle hey
what's up not letting anybody get behind
him standing fa in on the marry Go the
whole time the marry the merry gound
yeah you know what Merry gound is sure
the thing that spins around I know what
eighth grader was going to do that well
we used to hang out there at the Margo
round at the park at the like the public
park I'm thinking like you're thinking
of an actual Mar around with the up and
down horses fully fully talking you go
around you're talking about the the the
twisty turny thing the metal thing yeah
yeah I saw a video where they hooked a
chain up to that attach it to a got hurt
they got hurt those dude's heads come
off they don't see that they don't think
that thing was dangerous without the
[__] hooking it up to a thing it had
the I don't know what the the term for
it is but like the metal that had like
the little like rivets on it yeah sheet
metal yeah that would get 9,000 de burn
in the back I remember
I went to uh Holland Elementary and
there was this stainless steel
slide man I'm talking there should have
it should have been caution tape around
it we' go out there and [__] you know
early late August or early dude [__]
sizzling D it was so long too you'd be
halfway down like trying to jump off the
middle the hell man shirt goes up naked
skin on that it was also I mean like it
is you know uh it it was all just metal
just I remember I was was in like fourth
grade when they put finally put plastic
in and it's like
dude we you know you're coming with like
blisters and stuff on your hands yeah
they did that at uh Shady Grove
Elementary the year that I was I think
in fifth grade old bad jungle gy swing
set like that could kill you like it was
metal from Pearl
Harbor that they reused brutal still had
bullet holes in it and [__] like that M
and they came in I don't know where they
got this money
but this thing was state-of-the-art it
was metal and it had the plastic
covering around it oh yeah wo had the
little little Crows Nest where you can
go up there with the steering wheel or
whatever A lot of them had that Tic Tac
Toe thing you could like flip around and
play yeah they put the uh the railroad
wooden things around it to to fence it
off and then mulch in the middle it
couldn't tell us nothing those had big
in the 90s for us they were always like
yellow and blue that's when I was like
oh that's somebody just got new the
taxes just went up in the town to pay
for that real nice um damn yeah I
remember getting so [__] hurt on
those things though Jam [__] bees
nest everywhere good night catch a was
Nest you pull out a little like a little
cap on the end peek in there [__]
four wasp sitting there looking at you
with guns yikes go back into class you
got [__] wood chips in your shoes and
[__] [__] suck smelling like a
[__] smelling like a Rat's
Nest that fresh molz was tough yeah get
that on you kicking you smell like a
dead
cat uh all right this one's from Josh is
it garbage if your local convenience
stores sell single batteries both double
A and AAA they got to be open in the
pack on that you get double A Lucy
that's what do you need one battery for
One battery expensive man but what's
running off one battery you need one one
that's I'm I'm asking you get one from
the remote or one from somewhere else
you just need one that's a very New York
Bodega thing sure of like you can buy
the Lucy you can buy a single stamp they
don't they're doing whatever they
they're opening up packages or you know
here take one potato trip they don't
care give me give me a handful of
Skittles got a piece of gum out of
here yeah they really don't care uh I
remember that first time I learned I
could buy one stamp I thought I I was I
thought it was like a drug deal my
roommate was like yeah just go into that
corner store they'll say you stamp I was
like one
in my head I'm committing a federal how
many St committ a federal crime um two
to three enough maybe 10 in my whole
life maybe 10 probably maybe 20 what
were you mailing I myself letters and
stuff like that risque
photos um my wife lived in Germany for a
while so I would send stuff like that
would you would you write like letters I
have yeah really uhhuh did you put a
little Spritz of cologne on there put
some honey mustard sauce put some
lipstick on the end give it a oh my God
said packages and stuff the spelling
errors those those letters were littered
with dude you love letters I mean you're
really paying me into a corner on this
one welcome to the
show but you would send actual letters I
have I wouldn't you know not with a
package not okay I'm talking just a
letter maybe once H maybe once man if we
get our hands on that I think iy just
found it not too long ago or a picture
of it or something or she found or
something oh what color was the envelope
did you go pink I used to steal the
stationer from my day job I I did it
from the wall she thought you she
thought you was getting sued I never
opened them plausible
deniability yeah that AB nobody signed
for that
certified oh man that's a dumb look
you're opening up your letter with do
whom it may
concern I never understood that remember
when they tried to teach you how to
write like a business letter where it
was like the address of who it was sent
to and then it was like almost like a
CCC type thing care of or whatever there
was like a name and an address and a
name and an address underne was also
getting a copy oh man they tried to
teach me that where in jail
what what are you talking about I don't
know I remember taking like uh you know
in some class had to write like a formal
letter in high school mhm and I didn't
get it at all you know what I'm saying
no I didn't understand how to do that
dear parole board I knew I knew to start
a paragraph that you pushed in a little
bit okay well that's not that that okay
they don't do that no more did they no
you yeah no you do I think yeah yeah
yeah for sure if you're typing a paper
yeah oh it's all now word processing
does it all because I've always been
very impressed with you about how to do
a a business
email sure I've worked in the business
you know i' worked at law firms and
stuff I had I didn't think anybody put
anything in the subject line yeah he
said that to me very recently he goes
people don't use that do they I'm like
everybody I thought that was like a
faxa that was like saying you know not
that I know of no like yelling what yeah
I thought that was yelling it's how
paranoid you were I you mean like that
cyber m
or something freaking I'm
sorry yeah I ain't get that [__] at all
yeah
um I learned it I guess I learned some
of it in business school but like you
know I think yeah I don't
know I mean never really like drafted
letters I learned all that stuff just
from like papers and stuff and then
email like nobody was like
sending everything was just done via
[__] email you learn that more email
more email etiquette than anything yeah
they were still teaching us how write
like a formal business letter I still
don't like I mean like I'll do it with
like you know uh the suits will send us
stuff and like people will be CCD and
everything and I a lot of times I just
cut all those people out and just I'm
like I don't reply back I I won't reply
all oh really yeah I don't need all
these people in my business power move I
like that this is between me and you
yeah iing let's get the audience out of
here see if you're still a tough
guy see if you're still running your
mouth behind closed
doors no I do that sh with that
everybody see if you're still hit me
with the all caps uh-huh well it's just
also too confusing I don't you know with
like you know you know a show or
something I'm like I don't know
everybody's name at the venue or the
something and then you know I'm like
just give me the I need all I need to
know is the person I'm talking to that
was the same thing with business and in
business you really have to keep it all
that's all like plausible deniability of
like if you circumvent the email chain
and cut people out you know you're up to
something they're up to yeah so they
want have like everybody's stuff is
documented be going
yo yo she's a [__] ain't she reply oh
[__] well that there I mean there's also
there's there big etiquette of that of
like you know per my previous email
means like [__] if you ain't see it up
there like I already done told your ass
I don't know how to do any of that stuff
yeah per my previous email means like
you're [__] up lady can you do
anything you know anything about that
stuff buddy I signed documents with an X
what are you talking about I think I
it's as much as we I've sent Toby three
emails I get any emails that's the way
we like it big guy I mean what what
would you email me I don't know yeah how
you doing hey buddy just another form of
communication you can bother me
with wouldn't mind getting my hands on
that love letter though uh yeah that's
not going to happen that's crazy that
makes sense I a love letter is a uh it
was a more of a bit at the time um I was
more of a poem
guy this so much worse sure this is if
you think this isn't a way for him to
just cram in his poetry into the show
you're dead wrong nobody asked what you
were and he pulls out a scroll actually
that was more of a poem gu book of short
stories Toby lower the
light uh sunny day and Other
Stories Life and Times of a fat ass the
death of a fat ass um yeah no it was
more of like uh I was b i v I just found
it recently it was more of like a
conversation we were having via text at
the time wasn't romantic no it was more
like yeah I think I was she was like I'm
working like why don't you send me a
letter or something I was like oh here's
your letter or something it was like
draw wiener me
[Laughter]
you stick figures banging yes no Circle
my boss what are you working on K this
is the Pensky
file uh you strike me as a pen pal kid
that you might have had a pen pal we had
one the schools would do though I think
I had one he just writing
convicts will you marry
me no no pen pals no no letters to speak
of really I think I one of my boys in
college oh had like a serious pen pal
all growing up we didn't know this
always freaked me out and then he's like
uh my buddy's coming just you know's
he's coming you know like that in
college Steve's coming for the weekend
and that was either hit or miss either
were usually missed if you either best
friends with that guy or you ended up
watching him getting beat up dude they
always got in fights cuz they couldn't
handle their [__] every single time they
either blacked out paused the scene at
the pizza place or got their ass kicked
in the basement of a party yeah every
time this dude showed up I think he was
Australian or something like that and
this guy caused a problem and I'm like I
think like Saturday after the first
night we're like how do you know this
guy like did he he's like he was my pen
pal growing up I'm like what you're
[__] Ben pal you're vouching for this
guy that's writing letters in the summer
that's nuts um I I think I have I would
love to I don't think he would let me my
buddy you I think the I think the street
term is served the bid uhuh so I would
write him letters Ah that's cool uhhuh
and they he would write them back mad
Hood like which is crazy to write out
[__] like Hood language
like like dat with be that you know what
I mean like how do you spell n I'm
saying he knew it was always it was
always C Facebook was always nuts too
when people would type hood and [__]
you're like what the [__] you have to
try to do that dude I've never seen
[__] written in
cursive fountain
pen I figured you got to do that in the
can just in case anybody get the can
yeah when you're in the clink in case
anybody gets their hands on you really
think you're someone else in case
somebody gets to hands on it sure yeah
you know they write love letters sending
[Laughter]
kites Whispering sweet nothing I mean
it's a telling your mom how hard it is
that don't get you that's a great clip
that I love bud you ever see the talking
on the I would always I I would be
putting it did you kill that
[__] yet somewhere PS did you
kill that [__] BS I'm mad as
[__] yo and end in the sentence with yo
written is crazy
dude yo y'all be
whing yeah he was he was send us these M
Hood letters
dude it was crazy it was nuts all
written wild like exclamation points and
[__] like tagged up like B you know like
some things would take up like T pal
feeling obligated to write them back you
can't just leave him hanging cuz then
he's getting out I know he didn't write
me I know
but still a good friend served his time
paid his debt to society now he's
[__] killing it there you go he's
doing better than some other guys in the
team which is
crazy dude he got out of he got out of
jail got a job in like a work release
program and then my buddy he got my
other buddy a job who wasn't in jail
we're like dude you had a four-year Head
Start you had a fouryear head start on
this guy he's getting you a
job what are you even doing this old
time uh oh my God but we got to wrap it
up gang that's the time for today gang
love you to death uhhuh probably a
couple tickets left for that Philly show
yeah Philly show uh I don't have my
numbers in front of me but very limited
tickets if any get them johnes now and
we'll see you there we love you and
we'll see you next week peace peace